[Music]
after the deaths at astroworld travis
scott shuts down his show to calm a
rowdy crowd
[Music]
and an iconic artist collapses
mid-concert plus no osiris on overcoming
addiction
[Music]
what caused her habit and the low that
led to her lasting change i also
struggle with heavy anxiety and
depression
[Music]
kim kardashian and northwest take paris
fashion week but the nine-year-old has
some questions why do you have to wait
for us all the time
et's the download starts now
we begin with the murder trial for the
man accused of killing grammy
award-winning rapper nipsey hussell eric
holder is likely headed to prison we the
jury in the above entitled action
find the defendant eric ronald holder jr
guilty of the crime of first degree
murder
the 32 year old was charged for gunning
down the musician outside of his la
clothing store back in 2019 he was also
found guilty of two counts of attempted
voluntary manslaughter after two
bystanders were injured during the
shooting the jury deliberated for about
six hours in total before reaching a
verdict prosecutors argued that holder's
attack on the la-based rapper was
calculated and premeditated he's facing
life in prison and will be sentenced at
a later date
nipsey was rising to stardom with his
first studio album victory lap just a
year before he passed
this time around i'm gonna make it clear
spoken danger to the universe
a real soldier somebody that
light is gonna spread on the world
forever he touched so many people come
from hip-hop i mean he should have got
this while he was alive he felt like a
brother to me like when my dad talked to
him we're a very private family i know
we're in the entertainment business but
there's not too many people that came in
our family circle that felt like family
and that's what nipsey was
and for those that knew nipsy hustle
personally you knew he had nothing but
love for every gang member from southern
california when you make music you come
from the dirt one thing about a
neighborhood we gonna respect another
man from another neighborhood even if he
ain't from our neighborhood if he come
from where we come from you are a peace
advocate nil
that's what you are
the late rapper leaves behind two
children including a son with actress
lauren london
my pain is for my two-year-old that
probably won't remember how much his dad
loved him
moving on to travis scott putting a
performance on pause amid a crowd safety
scare the concert chaos happened at a
fourth of july concert at coney island
according to tmz the rapper was
performing an impromptu set with meek
mill when several concert goers climbed
up a metal lighting structure
as soon as travis spotted the fans he
immediately stopped the show yeah
respectfully
you guys got to get down for lincoln
that collapse is going to be a bad vibe
we do not need that
a spokesperson for travis tells e.t he
is committed to doing his part to ensure
events are as safe as possible so that
fans can have fun travis still faces
multiple lawsuits following november's
astroworld concert tragedy 10 people
were killed in a massive crowd surge the
rapper was scheduled to headline the day
in vegas festival in september which
would have been his first headlining
event since astroworld but the show was
canceled for logistical reasons and
scary moments at a carlos santana
concert after the legendary guitarist
collapsed on stage the grammy winner was
in the middle of his set in michigan on
tuesday when he sat down on a drum riser
then fell
backward that's weird he must be hot or
dizzy and he needs to sit then all of a
sudden he started slumping and he fell
where's the ems
there they are an eyewitness tells e.t
temperatures reached 90 degrees the day
of the show and that the paramedics were
working with santana for at least 30
minutes before they got him up when they
did he seemed to be in good spirits
conscious and waving to fans as he was
wheeled off the stage but turns out the
74 year old was suffering from heat
exhaustion and dehydration santana's
publicist tells e.t that he was taken to
the er for observation and is doing well
the musician who had emergency heart
surgery in december wrote on facebook
that he forgot to eat and drink water
and says he's taking it easy after the
on stage scare santana is currently on
tour alongside earth wind and fire
tonight's show in pennsylvania has been
postponed
now on to hayden panettiere's
heartbreaking confession she was once
addicted to drugs and alcohol hayden
says the opioid drug use started when
she was just 15. she claims people on
her team gave her quote happy pills to
make her peppy in interviews and it led
to years of drug abuse that became so
severe she nearly suffered liver failure
the 32 year old actress tells gma and
people mag it got even worse in 2014
following the birth of her daughter when
she battled postpartum depression
where did you turn to for support the
bottle the bottom of a bottle i didn't
have any negative feelings towards my
child i just knew i was deeply depressed
in 2018 she made the tough decision to
send her daughter to the ukraine to live
with her dad hayden's ex vladimir
klitschko so that she could seek
treatment i felt like i was walking
blind and there was nobody
there that was really able to support me
in the way that i needed to be supported
and i don't like to ask for help either
you know i want to be that strong stoke
woman it turned out to be the right
decision she spent time in the hospital
to be treated for jaundice and then
eight months in rehab to face her demons
how are you today
i'm good it's an everyday
battle i'm grateful to say that i'm
sober today and hidden will soon be back
at work in scream six while she'll
revive the character kirby reed i called
them up myself and was like so you guys
don't like happen to want to bring kirby
back do you
i did i wanted to be in it that badly i
don't think anyone's gonna be
disappointed all right here's another
surprise guys noah cyrus is in recovery
too and has been for almost two years
in a new interview with rolling stone
the singer opens up about her addiction
to xanax which she says began when she
was 18. she tells the mad quote my
boyfriend at the time was the first
person that gave me a xanax and it
became a way for us to bond while noah
doesn't mention the boyfriend by name we
do know she was dating rapper lil xan at
the time who since rebranded as diego
got a lot of feelings for her
okay so are we in love like what's
happening yes of course i'm obsessed
with him
he's my best friend but in late 2018 the
two split and noah told e.t she saw
their time together as a learning
experience
i learned a lot about relationships in
the past few years there's obviously
like ups and downs to relationship and
i also struggle with heavy anxiety and
depression and that's pretty hard noah
also admits she was constantly
surrounded by people with easy access to
the pills and recalls a dark time when
she nearly fell asleep during a tv
interview she says i was completely
nodding off and unable to keep my head
up or my eyes open because i was so far
gone
by the time the pandemic hit in 2020
noah's struggles were at their worst so
much so that they got in the way of her
getting to say goodbye to her
grandmother who died later that year
that's when noah says she made the
decision to get help it's like noah just
take a time to take the time to work on
yourself and make yourself happy and it
was music that really seemed to dig noah
out of what she calls a bottomless pit
[Music]
she channeled her feelings into her
first album the hardest part which will
drop on september 16th less than two
years after earning a best new artist
nomination at the
[Music]
we grammys need to just live in this
moment and that's just something that
like i am so grateful for and
i'm just so blessed to be here
[Music]
meanwhile queen elizabeth is taking a
bigger step back from her official
duties in may her majesty missed the
opening of parliament due to episodic
mobility problems she even missed some
of the events during her platinum
jubilee after experiencing some
discomfort with the trooping of the
color and now in the palace's sovereign
grant report released last week the list
of duties she must fulfill as head of
state has been removed which means the
queen can attend to what she can while
prince charles the future king fills in
for his 96 year old mother prince
william is expected to take on more
responsibility as well this is the first
time in more than a decade that there's
been a formal change to the queen's
duties and the biggest clue yet that the
crown is looking to the future
because we are seeing the monarchy enter
a mode of transition we have an aging
monarch the queen is now 96 years old
prince charles will turn 74 this year i
think william recognizes that his father
can through age alone only really be a
transitional king i think in terms of
the future of the monarchy william is so
key to all of it
meanwhile william's wife k middleton can
add a new skill set to her resume
photographer the much snapped royal step
behind the camera to capture her
mother-in-law camilla for the cover of
country life magazine in honor of the
royal 75th birthday the duchess of
cornwall guest edited the issue and
commissioned the other duchess to
capture the cover image very nice there
now on to american royalty kim
kardashian making her big debut at paris
fashion week
there she is walking in the balenciaga
show in a skin-tight asymmetrical gown
with attached gloves her heels are built
into her leggings too and kim couldn't
be more excited sharing the major moment
on instagram she was in good company
duolipo was on the catwalk too along
with bella hadid naomi campbell nicole
kidman and selling sunset star christine
quinn but the real scene stealer was
kim's nine-year-old daughter north who's
been looking chic all week and gave the
photographers outside a piece of her
mind
[Music]
why do
[Music]
i'm sure kim got some catwalk tips from
her supermodel sister kendall jenner who
by the way may or may not be embracing
that single life the source tells et
that kendall and rx nba pro devin booker
are hanging out after their split last
month the source adds they are in a good
place right now they spent 4th of july
weekend in the hamptons together and had
a really fun time and despite what
people may think kendall and devin still
have a lot of love for each other it's
not always easy but i don't know i just
kind of i like to keep my private life
pretty private so
i try my best but at the same time i
don't i don't like to let being seen out
in public with someone like affect my
everyday life
you know last month multiple sources
told us that kendall and devon were
still going their separate ways because
kendall feels like they're on different
paths however the source did say that
there was a possibility that they could
get back together you know we learn and
again our boundaries may change one day
depending on the situation but
yeah
now on to kendall's other big sister
khloe kardashian who just confessed
she's got a crush of a crush
yes can i see your crush please
ah coco fakes us out a little bit her
crush is her four-year-old daughter true
but i mean can you blame her exactly
never now we know chloe has officially
ended things with true's dad tristan
thompson when it was revealed that he
cheated again
everything is
an act of betrayal everything is a lie
everything is
manipulation the entire thing is
despicable
yep but don't worry you guys because
chloe is doing just fine in the romance
department of source told et last month
that she's dating someone new his
identity is unknown but the source says
the mystery man is a private equity
investor that kim introduced her to at a
dinner party all in all chloe is in a
good headspace and things are going well
for her that's the goal is finding
someone to do nothing with it's the best
because you can do everything with
a new group of singles are looking for
their special someone to sit around and
do nothing with the twist they're
perfect strangers married at first sight
is back tonight and for the first time
it's headed to the west coast
san diego is filled with sunshine
beaches and attractive men who never
want to grow up
you got this mitch i had literally never
heard of married at first sight i am
freaking out right now
i had horrible dating experiences awful
luck at love so i was hoping that this
would be it let's break it down by the
numbers it's season 15 and we'll see 10
singles take the plunge in tonight's
premiere of married at first sight on
lifetime after two months of marriage
they'll decide if they want to stay
married or get divorced we won't spoil
anything but we can tell you things
start strong first impression of my wife
at the house i was like
i was like he looks very familiar that's
all i'll say i want to throw up pass out
i just want to get this over with and
meet my husband why didn't anybody talk
me out of this i'm waiting at the altar
now and i'm really hoping that shrek
doesn't come down the aisle
come on shrek is so lovable though plus
that's like the point of the whole show
right all right guys stranger things
fans may be hoping to see joyce and
hopper walk down the aisle in season
five but right now they can't seem to
get enough of season four
hawkins will fall
[Music]
my friends need me
you're not ready
just days after the final two episodes
debuted netflix says it's now become
their second ever series to rack up over
1 billion hours viewed
the little easter egg for fans david
harbor is revealing a very 80s
connection to the stranger things
universe in an instagram post he shared
this sword used by hopper in an epic
season finale fight scene was also used
by the ultimate warrior arnold
schwarzenegger in 1982's conan the
barbarian david said it was a tremendous
honor to wield the iconic weapon and
from on set secrets to a potential
prequel david harbour says euphoria star
jacob olaudi is the ch his choice anyway
for a younger version of the beloved
hawking sheriff he told gq jacob could
pull off being as handsome as i was at
20. now we do know the duffer brothers
are developing at least one stranger
things spin-off that they say will be 1
000 different from the original
something else fans are excited to see
the new movie amsterdam from writer and
director david o russell talk about
a-list taylor swift margot robbie
christian bale rami malek and more the
crime epic follows three friends who
film themselves at the center of a
secret plot here's your first look so
two soldiers
and the nurse found ourselves in
amsterdam
we formed the pact and we swore to
protect each other
no matter what
we find ourselves in a situation where
we're accused of killing someone which
is not true this is all turning out to
be a lot larger than any of us i'm about
to do something that could cost me my
life
[Music]
oh that's fast
that's advantage oh that looks good
movie comes out in theaters on november
4th another film with a star-studded
cast the woman king starring oscar
winner viola davis as a female warrior
and e.t was on the set in south africa
fight
or we die
naniska is the general of the agojia
tribes the girls they couldn't you know
control and they became soldiers the
europeans wish to conquer us
some things
are worth fighting for
don't know
when i started the martial arts i was
like i'm 56 i'm a woman i can't take
down this dude i can't do this i can't
do that and then suddenly i could yeah
you know i saw my possibilities
to be a warrior you must kill your tears
it took star and producer viola davis
over six years to bring the true story
of the woman king to the screen the
movie that hits theater september 16th
includes john boyega from star wars
captain marvel's lashonna lynch and e.t
zone tondo glomo who sat down
exclusively with the cast on set for us
i think you draw so much inspiration
from your dad for this character
yeah i'm like how can i easily tap into
this you know big daddy energy big daddy
energy
i'm sick of you
bradley cooper and carrie mulligan are
nearly unrecognizable in costume while
filming the netflix movie maestro in new
york city in the film both actors are
aged up and aged down to tell the life
story of legendary composer leonard
bernstein who was openly gay but married
to a woman no release date yet but we do
know bradley is directing for the first
time since a star is born despite that
being his first directing job the movie
was nominated for best picture at the
oscars in 2019 et spoke with him that
same year about all the accolades
it's vulnerable you know writing you
know co-writing and telling a story and
directing it yeah i mean i i had no idea
what was going to happen i just knew
that i had to try
all right guys still ahead we're
chatting with actress rebecca
rittenhouse who's unleashing her psychic
powers in a new romantic comedy i just
want what everybody wants really at the
end of the day we all go through that
experience right where you're like maybe
this thing that i thought was meant to
be isn't meant to be
and it's beyonce's renaissance the new
record she just shattered with her new
single
[Music]
and download we'll be right back
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
well she's lost her mind but she's
breaking records today beyonce has
joined the elite company of michael
jackson and paul mccartney according to
forbes they're the only three artists in
history to have at least 20 top 10 hits
beyonce has break my soul to thank the
lead single offer upcoming album
renaissance out july 29th hit number
seven on billboard's hot 100 this week
and i am quite gangsta i should
say moving on to rebecca rittenhouse
who's channeling her inner psychic and
the new hulu comedy maggie out today she
plays 30 something who can see her
romantic future which you'd think would
make dating easier right well as et's
denny directo found out not so much
your character is a psychic but she also
has some trouble navigating the present
i'm not supposed to see my own future
this never happened before i was married
with a kid no way
you have to like talk to people to get
married
so how would you describe how maggie's
visions of the future kind of affect her
present though and like the things that
in the relationships she's trying to
pursue well she she assumes she knows a
lot of things that you know she often
finds out she's wrong later on you know
um especially when it comes to ben who
is her love interest and the pilot and
then she thinks she sees them ending up
together but then she has another vision
so it's like she's only getting bits and
pieces
she kind of uses her abilities as an
excuse not to really be in her life and
in the present moment and it's like well
sometimes like your life is just the
experience of living it and you got to
be there and you can't be so afraid of
making mistakes or being with the wrong
person i just want what everybody wants
really at the end of the day to unhook
our bras and eat noodles over the trash
there's this tight-knit group of close
friends too that she you know starts to
develop too how much fun was it to film
with this cast it looked like you guys
who had been friends for like years yeah
and and nicole sakura and i really
clicked right off the bat that's
hilarious by the way she's so i feel
like her performance reminds me of lisa
kudrow and friends like she's like
phoebe yes
oh my god i think she's hysterical okay
so if she's a phoebe maggie is the
sometimes i feel like maggie's got a
little bit of chandler in her i'm not
gonna lie kind of like the
self-deprecation maybe a little cynical
right you know okay i see that i love
that
so can we talk about maggie's fashion a
little bit oh yes i mean it's really
good it must be fun for you to get
dressed up right oh my gosh so pam
chilton who is the costume designer and
i had the best time i wear a lot of
vintage
she pulled a lot of stuff from the fox
vault and they you know because of ryan
murphy they had some like really cool
stuff from the 90s so i wear a lot of
vintage 90s belts and jackets i wear
this really cool leather fringe jacket
from the 90s and um i also wear this
dress in the prom episode that's one of
a kind it's vintage it's incredible
you're pulling some scream queen stuff
too like did you see the stuff from the
ryan murphy collection
everything we could she was like i kind
of feel guilty i was like how fun is
that okay so maggie ends on a bit of a
cliffhanger now without giving it away
what was your reaction when you first
read that well i don't give anything
away but it's sort of like what we're
rooting for you know and it's i think
it's so good because we you have this
arc of like where maggie accepts
that maybe the person that she was
hoping to be with or that she felt she
was destined to be with like you know we
all go through that experience right
where you're like
maybe this thing that i thought was
meant to be isn't meant to be and i'm
gonna move forward
um
but then there's some twitter there's
twists
then there's a twist i mean i was
excited i was that is life i did not see
that coming
[Music]
well family is forever and so is ray j's
new tattoo yup he got a giant portrait
of his sister's face on his thigh so i
guess jack harlow has no excuse now
who's ray j's sisters oh my god who's
reid's his sister yo he's fat he's
serious
he said no doesn't
he he's 24
you didn't know brandy brandy
or sibling
nobody's ever told me that in my life
all jokes aside we know the tat is just
one piece of ray jay's grand vision on
instagram the singer shared he's getting
his entire leg done in a quote-unquote
holy theme featuring family scripture
and positive affirmations and he wanted
to start off with his best friend now
brandy seems just as shocked as we all
are posting bro
in the comments with that handful of
hearts
i didn't mean it was that we have to
start doing now am i gonna have to get
denny and cassie tattooed on my back
cause i'll do it it's gonna cost us but
i'm gonna do it all right guys that's
gonna do it for us today make sure to
tune in tomorrow for a new episode of
et's the download bye
[Music]
you